is it true that you don't make that much
money as a private company we just have
the advantage of not necessarily having
to report to the outside world all of
our financials Facebook needs to find a
way to generate revenue and so
Zuckerberg is experimenting with ads say
you write on Facebook that you like a
certain movie that's turned into an ad
the real trouble started when they began
using a tracking program called Beacon
that monitors what you buy on over 40
websites and automatically reports it to
your friends without explicit permission
turning Facebook into something much
more commercial I actually think that
this makes it less commercial I mean
what would you rather see a banner ad
from Bloomingdale's or that one of your
friends bought a scarf criticism of
Beacon began to build but Zuckerberg dug
in his heels until he had a full-blown
PR disaster on his hands including
petitions and bloggers writing
obituaries